bonjour à tous
un communiqué un calendrier et la
volonté toujours d'afficher leur unité
tous les syndicats donnent rendez-vous
le mardi 6 juin pour une 14e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites 5 semaines c'est loin mais
c'est un compte premier intelligent ce
qui est important pour nous c'est de
trouver les voies et les moyens de
représenter le mouvement syndical d'une
telle façon que chacun pourra s'y
intégrer jako nous vient du sud du bien
des Bouches-du-Rhône
jako était agent administratif tout à
fait voilà aujourd'hui il est retraité
mondiaco c'est ça voilà autant vous dire
que la retraite à 64 ans il s'en bat les
steaks une date loin d'être anodine deux
jours plus tard le 8 juin à l'Assemblée
nationale sera examiné une proposition
de loi visant à Broger cette réforme des
retraites récemment promulguées l'Inter
syndicat l'appel est députés à voter ce
texte émanant du groupe yacht son
adoption ne marquerait que le début du
processus législatif mais serait un
camouflé pour la majorité qui se dit
serait on n'a jamais créé un vote pas
plus hier que aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le conseil de droit de l'homme a passé
trois heures à étudier la situation de
la France le plan des droits humains et
notamment sur la question des violences
policières et alors c'était le premier
même on serait que le premier avril
puisque vous avez eu l'Iran la Russie le
Venezuela
qui ont dénoncé les violences policières
en France
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a bien un moment où le débit il va
aller se rapprocher à 5 mètres de vous
pour aller ramasser un caillou et là
vous hésitez pas d'initiative vous allez
me le chercher dans la foule cet homme
vient justement d'être vu en train de
jeter un projectile dans son sac à dos
il en cache un autre plus impressionnant
on va faire un bon 1kg c'est pour quoi
faire la pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
ça ne passe pas non plus Quentin c'était
pas loin non plus oh que cette finale
est indécise
à l'école j'ai trop hâte de voir tous
mes frères et sœurs
[Musique]
là où je me dis pourquoi je suis jamais
parti en vacances
elle a la montagne parce que la montagne
m'aime pas
c'est l'invité surprise du maître gala
un cafard que personne n'attendait et
que tous les médias présents ont-ils
mortalisés
première loge le photographe Kevin
masure a pris le cliché de l'insecte en
plein ascension un court moment de
gloire pour cette blatte écrasée avant
d'avoir réussi à monter totalement les
marches
à Choupette il y en a eu trois hommages
à Choupette le chat adorer car Lagerfeld
ça c'est dojo 4 cette robe à la
nécessité plus de 5000 heures de travail
000 paires argentés et blanches mais
alors le clou du spectacle c'était ni
l’inness que vous avez vu tout argenté
ni de jockey c'était j'arrête Leto alors
personne ne savait qui se cachait
derrière ce gros chat géant cette
Choupette géante à l'intérieur du
déguisement hyper impressionnant c'était
l'acteur Jared Leto qui a eu bien chaud
et qui a bien galéré pour les interviews
dans la descente il faut vraiment
retenir le traîneau il faut le freiner
sinon ça peut être dangereux pour les
chiens
[Musique]
pour sortir incognito de leur hôtel
certains sont allés loin très loin
sa Commission européenne vient
d'autoriser c'était il y a quelques
semaines la mise sur le marché d'une
nouvelle catégorie d'insectes pour
l'alimentation humaine tout ça est très
sérieux oui c'est de la poudre de
Grillon domestique une sorte de farine
protéinée qui peut être utilisée pour la
fabrication de biscuits de barres de
céréales de pâte à pizza autorisation
qui a provoqué une sorte d'hystérie sur
les réseaux sociaux puisque certains ont
immédiatement pensé qu'on allait nous
faire manger des insectes de force sans
en informer qu'on ne laisse retrouver
avec du grillon un petit peu partout
alors je vous rassure ça n'est pas le
cas super vous voulez que je prenne le
relais c'est ça non je vais le manger
tout seul vous inquiétez pas
[Rires]
j'aime le mode de vie polluant mais ça y
est j'ai pris conscience qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose je pense c'est pas
mal au dernier jour de faire des piqûres
de rappel parce que c'est vrai qu'en
réalité on ne fait rien de sérieux
contre le dérèglement climatique
on aura voulu continuer bêtement avec
notre système complètement dingue si on
lance sa télévision dans un fleuve et
quand la ressort il se peut qu'elle
devienne un servables alors on lance sa
télévision dans un club et donc ils en
ont déduit une expression c'est ça le
truc les chiots ici les mangent pas il
les fume non fume la peau c'est pas
possible